hello everyone and welcome to some very
important news from the Chess World that
we know four of the candidates for the F
candidates tournament 2024 they are the
from the Chess World Cup Fabiano corana
prananda and N abasov also will be
joined by the uh former World CH
championship match run rup that is Yanni
pishi who lost to ding Lan and now they
are being joined by none other than
Hikaru Nakamura this is his yesterday's
game sorry about not showing it right
away I had to leave the country for it
and now he drew his game against arjuni
in the final round which means he
definitely qualifies for the fiday
candidates tournament now let's check it
out if you still haven't seen it uh it's
quite a masterful performance let's
check it out penultimate round hikaro
versus um Fabby and he opens with Pawn
to E4 uh we have Pawn to E5 Knight F3
Knight to F6 and now Knight to C3 Hikaru
could go for the main line with Knight
captures on E5 of of the petol of even
D4 Maybe Knight to C3 sorry Knight to C3
uh but he goes for the three Knights um
game we have Knight to C6 Fabby goes for
the four Knight's defense or the for
Knights game and now Pawn to D4 striking
the center at the so-called Scotch
variation e captures we have Knight
captures and now Bishop to B4 this is
the main line Knight captures uh B
captures and now Bishop to D3 again
completely in the main line Pawn to D5 e
captures and both players now Castle so
castles uh and castles you could go
after the C6 Pawn uh but it's uh nothing
impressive so uh instead white just
castles and sorry black recaptures with
C captures on D5 and now uh how do you
continue U the top move here is still
Bishop to G5 but hear Waits with it he
plays Pawn to H3 and now Bishop to E6
okay just continuing development we have
Queen to F3 and now Pawn to C5 grabbing
more space in the center we have Rook to
D1 and nicely aligning The Rook with
that Queen on d8 could become very
useful and uh Fabby decides to give up
the bishop pair with Bishop captures on
C3 which is a bold move yes you mess up
hiar Pawn structure but you do give him
the bishop pair so B captures and now
Queen to A5 putting pressure on the C3
Pawn you're not really attacking it
because imagine if you played Queen
captures on C3 then Bishop captures on
H7 check and you lose your queen but it
could become uh very relevant so Bishop
to G5 threatening to mess up the pawn
structure by playing Bishop captures on
F6 and Fabi goes Knight to E4 sort of
offers a knight with the pawn uh but
then again if Queen captures then you
will be able to capture on C3 so Bishop
captures D captures but now just Queen
to G3 being very annoying here you have
to worry about Bishop to H6 or Bishop to
F6 putting pressure on that G7 Pawn so
Fabby simply moves the king king to h8
now of course you try something like
this Fabby just captures the bishop uh
and now there is a game uh that was
played in the a open in 2016 between
Maxim lugowski and David gorian where
Rook to D6 was played right away but
here we have Pawn to A4 and it is now as
of move 17 that we have a completely new
game as one would expect from such
incredible players like like hiar and
Fabby uh Rook F to E8 and now Rook to D6
going for The Rook lips maybe preparing
to double up on the dile pawn to H6
challenging the bishop and Bishop to F4
now we have Rook to E7 uh The Rook
nicely controls the seventh Rank and
also if needed uh maybe uh as the G7
Pawn might become a problem you might
play something like F6 or F5 to help out
with the defense uh Queen to E3 now
putting some pressure on C5 but really
putting all the pressure on the H6 pawn
and Fabby says bring it on he accepts
the challenge he plays Rook C Rook to C8
and now uh it's a very interesting
position where of course you know that
something must be up feel free to pause
the video and figure out what you would
do here while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
this very nice maneuver and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Bishop to E5 this is sort of
objectively strongest but it was not
played in the game the reason why it's
so strong is because Queen captures an
H6 is the thre now the G7 Pawn is pinned
and if you try to unpin with King to G8
then comes Queen G3 threatening
Checkmate and once you stop this here
comes Queen H4 threatening the rook and
once you move the Rook then Queen F6
will again Checkmate the black king so
what you will have to do after Bishop D5
is actually play King to H7 give up this
Pawn with check and now after something
like F5 you will play Queen to H4 again
as The Rook on E7 is defended this is
what you use in all of the lines to make
your tactics work and now once The Rook
is defended you will play play Queen to
G3 you will defend the pawn so you don't
have to worry about that you will have
constant pressure on that G7 Pawn uh the
bishop cannot move you have pressure on
G6 uh you're up material this is just
well objectively completely winning for
white uh but hiar win for Bishop
captures an H6 right away which is still
completely winning unless Fabby finds
this sort of a an an engine Miracle
defense uh that he doesn't uh he has to
play Rook to D7 here but instead he
plays Pawn to F6 now uh what happens if
you capture well if you capture then
just Queen captures on H6 with check
King to G8 and now Queen to G5 with
check King goes to f8 and now Queen F6
and this is a problem uh this will be
Checkmate and if you try to move the
king to G8 then you hang the Rook on E7
and if you try to move the Rook to sort
of make room for the King on E7 uh then
you run into Rook captures on E6 the
pawn is pinned cannot capture if Rook
captures then of course Queen h8 check
you pick up the Rook on C8 uh you up two
Pawns you're completely winning uh okay
maybe black could pick up this pawn and
you're only down one Pawn but then Rook
D1 you're checkmating the black king and
there's no real good way to escape if
you play King F6 then Queen to h8 check
picks up the queen on C3 and what else
is there if you try to make room uh for
the King on E6 maybe with something like
Rook to D6 then Queen to C7 chck picks
up the Rook there's really no no way out
of this so instead after Bishop captures
on H6 Fabby tried Pawn to F6 that's why
the Rook was placed on E7 to add more
protection here but now comes Queen
captures on e4 now attacking the the
bishop on E6 so Queen captures on C3
attacking hikaru's Rook on A1 and now
Rook a to D1 uh we have Rook C to E8 and
now Rook to d8 putting pressure on the
eighth rank so Bishop to G8 and now we
have Queen to H4 threatening all sorts
of nasty discoveries here Queen captures
on C2 now if the bishop moves you can
just bring the queen back to H7 to help
out with the defense but now Rook one to
D3 cutting of the Queen's um reach to
the H7 Square so Bishop to H7 now you
don't have to worry about any um
discoveries Here and Now Rook three all
the way to D7 look at this beautiful
move by Hikaru point is that let's say a
trade on d8 happens you will play Rook
captures on d8 check and once the bishop
moves now comes Bishop captures on G7
with check uh the only uh Square you
have for King is to actually capture the
bishop and now just Queen G3 check the
king will have to move you will play
Rook Capt on G8 and uh yes okay you're
only down one Pawn but something like
Rook G4 followed by Rook to H4
checkmates the the black king you will
either suffer Checkmate or again severe
material loss so after Rook three to D7
Pawn to G5 was played by Fabby uh but
now Queen to G3 uh we have Queen to B1
with check King to H2 and queen to F5
but now Rook captures on E7 we have Rook
captures on d8 and queen to C7 uh
putting pressure on the on the Rook here
here so Queen to F4 with check forces a
queen trade but it doesn't help Fabby
hear just trades captures captures and
now Bishop to G7 with check and the
problem is not that Hikaru is winning a
pawn because it's it's an end game of
Bishops of opposite colors uh the
problem is that after this um uh sorry
that after Bishop captures on F6 now the
threat is Rook captures on H7 followed
by just Bishop captures on d8 so Fabby
has to deal with this he moves the
bishop all the way to B1 but now Rook to
G7 check King to f8 and now Hikaru could
go for the second Pawn with Rook
captures on A7 but he says no we can go
into Bishops of opposite color he trades
the Rooks captures captures and now just
Bishop to G5 he says what do you do with
the pawn on the dark Square Fabby says
of course I cannot save it I only have a
light Square Bishop but I can at least
mess up your Pawn structure hikaro says
nope nope you cannot even do that he
plays Pawn to G4 uh Pawn to C4 Fabby
starts advancing his past Pawn but now
King King to G3 with Bishop to E4 and
now Bishop to D2 uh with this move uh
move 40 has been reached so time control
has been reached and he was in this
position on move 40 that Fabiano Carana
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh for those of you
who like it when I show why and I finish
the games well it's just that you have
two connected past pawns on the king
side and it doesn't matter that it's end
game of Bishops of opposite color and
that black is down only one Pawn the two
connected passers and the king side are
too decisive to give an example let's
say you play something like King F6 King
will come here you will move the bishop
somewhere Bishop to C3 check and now you
start making progress here on the king
side you will start okay Pawn to A5 you
don't want to blunder a Pawn King to F7
Pawn to H4 you will move somewhere with
the king king to G5 You'll Play Pawn to
H5 check of course you want your pawns
and light squares as you have a dark
Square Bishop so you can use it in
between King H6 maybe okay now you have
to move the king back to to bring the
king here and start advancing in the
pawns if black prevents this then you
kick the king away King to F6 and now
you bring it back and now you have won
the G5 Square so King G7 G5 is coming
King to F7 again G6 pawns and light
squares as you have a dark Square Bishop
King G7 King to G5 check uh King to G5
and after you play something now comes
Pawn to H6 and that's all there is now
black will of course try to stop your uh
past pawns but now if you move then
white gets a queen and if you go to the
corner then Bishop to C3 will result in
check so this is why it's so pointless
to continue this of course Fabby knows
this and after Bishop to D2 uh he
resigned um the game uh so yeah very
nicely play played by Hikaru and like I
said we have the World Chess
Championship run rup in the candidates
now Yan pishi we have the top three
finishers of the Chess World Cup Fabiano
corana n abasov and um prananda and they
are now joined by Hikaru Nakamura and
yeah this wasn't maybe as intense for
for Fabby uh since he already reached
2800 in the tournament for who knows
which time and he already qualified for
the FED candidates tournament so it
wasn't you know really hanging in the
balance for him he of course wanted to
win the tournament H but for Hikaru it
did mean a lot but also very interesting
as Hikaru was sort of uh in the race
with ala fua as who will get the spot in
the feed candidates tournament by via
highest rating now that Hikaru qualified
via this event now uh ala will most
likely be eligible um the qualify V
rating if maybe Anish giri doesn't catch
up to him uh but we'll see uh a couple
of more spots to be decided let me just
uh check if we have the other because
there were still yeah uh so we do now
know the top two finishers of the FED
Grand Swiss as the game uh finished
while I was recording this video of
course the other one uh is viit gujrati
he is the other candidate qualified via
the the FED Grand Swiss and uh he won a
very very nice game uh while I was still
watching it it was still a draw uh but
he was able to take down Alexander PR it
was a very fierce game so that will be
the other game that I will uh show you
after this one so there are a few more
spots in the candidates uh one will be
decided via the highest rating for
January 2024 so there
still you know qu quite a lot can can
change as there are some uh who could
qualify let me just re refresh this so
ala f is currently 276 two on the live
ratings list and Anish gir is 2754 so
he's down by eight points but yeah uh
we'll see a lot can still happen wle so
is 2752 kakin 2750 Anand even 2748 U and
so on and so on so we'll see who gets
that and also there is the one spot will
be decided via the the the winner of the
Fay circuit
2023 uh so yeah very nicely done by
Hikaru taking down a uh sort of fa was
2800 in the live ratings going into this
game but now that he car defeated him he
again uh took him down from his 2,800
Throne so for the moment Magnus is still
the only 2800 player in the world uh but
yeah brilliant game by Hikaru even
though he didn't go for that sort of top
move by the engine here Bishop D5 Bishop
captures on H6 was sufficient uh you
know for uh for taking down a human uh
so once again really hope you enjoyed it
stay tuned for next game will be vit
versus PR I would like to thank Roman
manini Sams giant ttis farm Marvin
Sparrow Gart hlan and perforce love
Marie for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual uh um you know you can check
two of my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and once again sorry for no
videos yesterday I really had to leave
the country but if you have any favorite
games from the pen round do use #
suggestion and I will do my best to
cover it uh on Monday uh so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day